sonic mania has plenty of secrets the
game's term for unlocks that give you
access to new characters and abilities
for example you can play through the
entire campaign using Sonic's super
peel-out ability from Sonic CD however
you can also unlock what's known as and
Knuckles mode where a second player can
play cooperatively with you as knuckles
instead of tails those familiar with
internet memes will recognize this mode
as a direct reference to the very same
and Knuckles meme from a few years back
check out the antics that occur as we
play Sonic mania with a double dose of
knuckles what other secrets are
references did you enjoy seeing in Sonic
mania let us know in the comments below
give us a like and subscribe to our
YouTube channel while you're here make
sure to check out our Sonic mania video
review thanks for watching
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
No
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]